today I'm going to talk about a topic
that comes up often in discussions
around systemic change and individual
personal responsibility I got an email
over the weekend and this is why I'm
even talking about this today the email
said hey David a cuban-american streamer
Destiny also known to summon our
audiences Stephen Kenneth Destiny
Bonnell II was recently interviewed and
Destiny said it's not hypocritical to on
the one hand say hey we need these
systemic changes but on the other hand
to encourage people to take
responsibility and give advice that
tells people individually how to best
solve their situation even if you're not
making the systemic change now I haven't
been able to find the clip doesn't even
really matter because this is a very
important topic and I want to talk about
it today because people have said to me
I get emails you know when we do uh
segments on the finance channel channel
or people call in during live calls with
personal finance questions or whatever
the case may be people write to me
they'll say David how can you in good
conscience and in good faith advise
people about how to reduce their own tax
liability for example or work to reduce
your own but to advocate for higher
taxes for some people or another example
recently that came up I spoke about uh
funding a 529 College savings account or
educational savings account for my baby
daughter and people say how can you
participate in creating a 529 account
for your baby daughter while saying a
huge problem is that college education
is too expensive there are too many
student loans
the stock market is not accessible to
everyone maybe college education should
be less important I'm going to address
those specific questions but let's first
set this up properly
many people on the right
and even some on the left will argue
there's a hypocrisy to demanding
systemic change while encouraging people
to take responsibility for their own
lives and to do what is best for them in
the moment some will say and they say it
to me if you believe in the systemic
change then you should wait for the
government to fix the problem and not
bother trying to improve your situation
others might argue when you do what is
best for you it actually will delay the
systemic solution that you might be
calling for this is a very flawed and
sometimes absurd argument first of all
demanding a systemic change and
encouraging individual action are not
mutually exclusive in fact I would argue
they go hand in hand imagine we want to
see a more equal Society we would like
to see the government policy to reduce
inequality in society well we need to
demand policies that address systemic
inequality like a living wage and
affordable house in universal healthcare
and we should vote for candidates who
will do those things or who say they
will do those things but at the same
time
why wouldn't I encourage people to
educate themselves about how things are
today how things work today to improve
their skills to advocate for rights in
the marketplace to take advantage of the
tools that are available to them which
they might not even know about to
improve their lives today as we work to
elect officials who will make the bigger
systemic change secondly for me as a
progressive demanding systemic change is
not about giving up personal
responsibility it's about acknowledging
here's all the things I can do but there
is a superstructure a systemic reality
that is above and beyond what I can do
it doesn't mean I don't do the things I
can do it means I understand there's a
second layer to it some on the right
like to say listen you want health care
for all so that you David is a
self-employed person don't have to buy
your own health care that's that's what
I do right now
sure maybe but
I'm going to get myself health care
because I need health care it's not
really about whether I am getting Health
Care on the marketplace uh the
healthcare.gov while saying everybody
should get these are two different
things we're all products of our
environment and our choices are limited
by the opportunities and obstacles that
exist systemically but within that we
should still do what we can do to
improve our situation and if we want to
empower people to succeed we should
create a society that provides equal
opportunity when it comes to education
and health care and other economic
opportunities last thing encouraging
individual action also doesn't mean we
ignore the systemic inequality I I would
argue it's the opposite when I say to
people here are the actions you can take
I'm empowering them to do that and
better set themselves up to challenge
the status quo and to demand that change
when we encourage workers to organize
and demand better wages and working
conditions we're trying to improve their
lives but we're also trying to make a
systemic change that will benefit more
than just them now let's talk about some
of the specifics as they apply to me or
people that sometimes call in or
whatever the case may be I let's talk
about taxes I pay every dollar in taxes
that I'm legally required to pay at a
systemic level I think we need higher
top tax rates we should look at taxing
capital gains as income we should
eliminate the carried interest loophole
we should shift the tax burden away from
the poor all of these different things
at the individual level me David pakman
just sending more money to the IRS and
not taking deductions that are available
to me that's not policy that it's just
that's not the way we do it my policy
opinion is the one I just told you and I
vote for elected officials that would
put that in place for everyone at the
individual level I'm not going to pay
more tax than I'm legally required to
pay I'm not going to send money to the
IRS for no reason there is no double
standard the problem is an individual
taxpayers it's the systemic loopholes
and tax breaks
that let the wealthy incorporations
evade taxes the 529 account for my
daughter I'll do this one
if College costs keep going up as they
have been by the time my daughter is 18
the colleges I went to would cost over
two hundred thousand dollars a year
that's insane seems can't possibly
happen I spoke to Adam Schiff about this
the student loan industrial complex is a
mess maybe jobs should not require a
college degree and that'll put downward
pressure on the cost of college well
maybe maybe not
but what do I gain by denying my
daughter a 529 account that I can start
funding today I will advocate for change
and I will also do what I think gives me
the best insurance policy she doesn't go
to college or she doesn't need the money
from the 529 because we fixed the cost
of college or whatever in 18 years I can
change the beneficiary or take the money
out and pay the 10 penalty whatever
now to an advice example if someone came
to me and said I'm struggling I need to
make some more money or I want to make
more money am I going to rant to them
about income inequality tax loopholes
for the rich and that we should have
Universal basic income those are
systemic ideas I would tell them have
you looked at a side business is there a
certificate you can get to earn more
money at your current job is your resume
updated is there a skill you can
monetize there is not a hypocrisy or
double standard between advocating for
systemic change
and in the meantime advising people to
do what is best for their families when
people we have a caller who called in
and said
I have a trans my partner is trans or my
daughter is trans
um
I live in a deep red State it's getting
really ugly they're passing all this
legislation systemically we should work
in every state to protect trans people
at the individual level I said to them
you've got to decide for yourself do you
need to move to a different state if
you're able to
in order to do what you think is best
for your family right now sure in 20
years we might effectively protect trans
people in whatever state it was they
were calling from but in the immediate
if your family is in danger well how I'm
going to say it's no you've got to stay
there and of course not okay not a
double standard let's understand the
difference between the systemic and
structural and the individual apparently
Ben Shapiro believes that localities
could or should ban men
[Applause]
from wearing women's clothes you heard
that right according to the pro-freedom
folks it's not enough that we live in a
society where people can wear whatever
they want we need to restrict what
people can wear on the basis of their
gender now I'm gonna play the clip for
you and you're gonna notice that there
are some real complexities here about
how you would even enforce this I would
argue it's not even legal but remember
this is someone who's about freedom and
listen to what he's calling for
she's wearing dresses and skirts be
illegal for men in public if so should
wearing pants for women be illegal in
public well pants not so much because
there is a female version of pants that
is nearly indistinguishable in many
cases from from male bands um but men
wearing traditional female clothing in
public I think there's a case the local
Zone that local community should be able
to stop at sure and they have local laws
about being naked or or indecent
exposure or at least we used to
what
because he's reading some chat message
now
see if he says more about it
looking very closely at chat messages I
guess
have I seen Kyle dunnigan's fresh
present DC work okay no he's off he's
off to something else now so the
argument here is municipalities should
be allowed to ban men from wearing
women's clothing I guess under some kind
of indecency thing if you can ban nudity
then you could ban a man from wearing a
skirt this is
absurdly stupid absurdly stupid and
again it's counter to the principle of
low regulation and freedom and liberty
that these right-wingers claim to
espouse number one
almost certainly this would be against
the law an ordinance at the local level
to restrict what clothing people can
wear based on the traditional gender
placement of that clothing would
probably be against the law the
Constitution guarantees the right to
freedom of expression that includes the
right to dress however you want if you
attempt to restrict that based on gender
Norms you would almost certainly violate
the equal protection Clause of the 14th
Amendment they say they're for Law and
Order this would almost certainly be
illegal they will often cite the
obscenity exemption arguing that a man
in a skirt is somehow obscene is going
to be a very very tough legal argument
to make but let's put legality aside for
a second talk about the Practical
absurdity of this proposal for starters
what are traditional women's clothes the
answer varies by society and it varies
by time period In some cultures men wear
skirts or dresses in others women wear
pants or other items that might be
considered mask the idea that there's a
clear and fixed line between what when
men and women should wear is untrue in
addition to that traditional wear even
within the United States there are
dramatic cultural differences between
what is typical between what is seen
regularly in different parts of the
country but beyond that
Scotland has men that wear kilts I guess
in Los Angeles men quote don't wear
kilts but is it based on where you're
from or where you are and then can you
actually say to Scotsman in La who want
to wear a kilt you can't do that because
here the men don't wear it and in
Scotland it's just ridiculous it is
ridiculous and it is another one of
these ideas from the so-called Freedom
crowd to control people's lives based on
arbitrary changing and outdated Notions
of gender roles and there's this broader
pattern of them wanting to do this it's
on access to health care we're going to
decide what procedures are legal and
when it's on voting no early voting and
no mail in voting and no voting in the
poor Democratic areas or whatever the
right to exist without fear of
discrimination oh let's ban men from
wearing women's clothes every single
instance of this needs to be pushed back
against if they claim to be about
individual freedom
then they can't also argue for something
that would arguably violate the
constitution on the basis of the
opinions of what manly men are supposed
to wear it's absurd it's ridiculous and
it goes against what they want you to
believe they actually stand for make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube
youtube.com slash that's a forward slash
the David Pacman show we'll take a very
quick break what a program today really
folks
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
well my gardening skills have certainly
improved over the years as many of you
know but I still have not figured out
how to get a money tree pumping out
bills every week and so that's why we
still are mostly funded by our audience
through the membership program you'll
get access to the Daily bonus show
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show and so much more David
Pacman does not have a soul
he doesn't have a soul I don't promise
anything about souls Candace Owens is
right but I do promise a good time on
the bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indicted you all know what it means
to get yourself a discount I'm going to
play something very interesting for you
today it's delusional it's deranged it's
backwards as much of the American right
wing is but it opens up a very
interesting conversation a republican
candidate for Governor Mark Robinson who
happens to be black and this is very
relevant to what we're going to hear
from him is in favor of reparations
but not the kind you might think of what
Mark Robinson
says he wants for reparations is black
people should give white people
reparations as a thank you for ending
slavery
yes now I know you're saying wait but
David that doesn't make sense for so
many different reasons of course but
let's first listen to what he had to say
and it's full ridiculous glory and then
we will talk about it some people that
we're talking about reparations in this
country they wanted reparations and I
remember I made this particular liberal
so angry at me because I told him right
to their face nobody owes you anything
for slavery
if you want to tell the truth about it
it is you who owes
it's you who owns whoa why do you owe
because somebody in those fields took
strikes for you
somebody after those fields were ended
and slavery was ended somebody had to
walk through Jim Crow for you
somebody fought Wars and died for you
somebody lived less than because they
didn't have what you have and they did
it for you
there are people in their graves right
now
and they are there because they were
willing to stand up and fight for you
those folks on the Edmond Pettus Bridge
carrying American flags take that Colin
Kaepernick
living in a society that he could
scarcely acknowledge something that he
has never known living with a bigotry
that none of us can imagine right
carried American flags on that bridge
and when they were hit upside the head
with night sticks and shot with water
hoses and knocked to the ground they got
up and picked those flags up and kept
marching all right so I guess he's
saying not only do black people today
oh white people reparations they also
owe earlier black folks who are no
longer alive reparations which is weird
so this is this is unreal stuff and this
is what happens when you just become a
contrarian for the sake of contrarianism
now I think that there are perfectly
reasonable critiques about reparations
and we've talked about them before you
can come down on either side as far as
reparations go but the idea that black
people owe white people money
for freeing them from slavery ignoring
that they were the ones enslaving the
black folks to begin with is really
something else it's like asking for
praise for putting out a fire that you
started and the other important thing to
remember is that many white people
including the slave owners didn't want
to end slavery he's sort of pretending
like listen white people ended slavery
so you should thank them no no no a
whole bunch of white people did not want
to end slavery and they lost the Civil
War over that
it's a wacky argument to make and by the
way
even after slavery was legally abolished
we still saw black folks facing
segregation of all kinds discrimination
oppression in the form of Jim Crow laws
systemic racism and so much of that
Legacy that we followed through hundreds
of years this is really wild and I'll be
totally honest with you
I don't even know if Robinson genuinely
believes this this is the virus the Mind
virus of contrarianism of if anybody on
the left is suggesting X then I need to
make clear that the opposite of X is
actually what we need I don't know
whether this is going to win them the
governorship or what but it is unreal to
see them saying these things out loud
and what's even crazier is people in the
crowd who decide to clap for it this
country has fallen very very far hey
here's some fascinating news my pillow
CEO and founder Mike Lindell known to us
of course simply as pillow we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines he has been ordered to pay five
million dollars
for his prove Mike wrong election fraud
challenge now pillow has been on the
show before
and he has this reward if you can prove
to me the election wasn't stolen I'll
give you five million bucks well a judge
is saying he's going to have to pay up
Washington Post report this is just the
best my pillow founder and prominent
election denier Mike Lindell made a bold
offer ahead of his cyber Symposium or as
he calls it a symposium he held in
August 2021 in South Dakota he claimed
he had data showing Chinese interference
and said he would pay five million
dollars to anyone who could prove the
material was not from the previous
year's U.S election he called it prove
Mike wrong on Wednesday a private
arbitration panel ruled someone did the
panel said Robert zeidman a computer
forensics expert uh oh sounds like a
cyber guy and 63 year old Trump voter
from Nevada
was entitled to the five million dollars
zeidman had examined lindell's data and
concluded not only did it not prove
voter fraud it has no connection to the
2020 election he was the only expert who
submitted a claim he turned to the
arbitrators after Lindell management
refused to pay him in a 23-page decision
the arbitrator said zeidman proved the
material from pillow unequivocally did
not reflect November 2020 election data
they have directed lindell's firm to pay
zeidman within 30 days zeidman says he's
really happy they clearly saw this as I
did that the data we were given at the
Symposium was not at all what pillow
said it was the truth is finally here
Zeidman's attorney said the panel's
decision is a warning to others who have
made wild allegations about election
fraud I will say this is not good for
pillow who is already taking loans to
keep his company afloat Lindell said in
a text to the post quote they made a
terribly wrong decision this will be
going to court in the meantime I have to
add my pillow is now uh under lawsuit
pillow is under lawsuit
in a major uh situation involving
Dominion voting systems this is a whole
other problem for pillow attacks on
Dominion voting persist despite
high-profile lawsuits this is an
argument an article from The New York
Times Dominion why don't you show us
what's inside your machines Mike Lindell
the Mike pillow executive and election
denier shouted during a live stream last
month he added that the company which
has filed a 1.3 billion dollar
defamation suit against him was engaged
in the biggest cover-up for the biggest
crime in United States history probably
in world history folks pillow is
destroying himself he told me when I
last interviewed him that he had spent
about 35 million dollars on all of this
nonsense I'm sure it is way more than
that at this point in time you've got to
add the 5 million bucks that he owes the
debunker and here he is explaining to
um Stephen Bannon that everybody got it
wrong everybody got it wrong LDS well it
is the reality is fake it's the biggest
scandal
um here I am on a family trip with my
grandkids and I attacked from all over
the country at news reporters calling me
all day isn't it kind of strange this
comes out the day after Fox settles with
Dominion this guy's not a cyber guy I
don't even know how he got in there with
his credentials he has he's an I.T guy a
computer guy but he's not he's an I.T
guy and a computer guy but not a cyber
guy can someone tell me what on Earth
Mike pillow thinks a cyber guy is
say well
this guy's wrong
again her left Democrats we only had a
you only get a little pool to choose
from
oh my goodness this guy is out of his
mind he really is and I have to tell you
it is sad to a degree I think pillow I
think pillow's life is in shambles and
he's even said there's not only been an
incredible Financial cost to all of this
there's been a family cost as well he's
traveling all the time he doesn't see
his family he's up and down on his plane
looking at voting machines and stained
ballots and all these different things
this guy has destroyed himself of his
own doing and it is sad to a degree but
he has been so corrosive and destructive
to the pillars of American democracy
that I have to say my my empathy only
goes so far he really does deserve what
he's getting even if he did a year of
this stuff he could have stopped a year
and a half ago and he wouldn't be in
nearly this much trouble so it's going
to cost him and it seems like it's going
to cost them big and if you uh look at
the clip we just played you can find it
on our Instagram or on our YouTube uh
Channel or Facebook wherever tick tocks
you really see that this guy is beaten
down and it doesn't make me happy but at
some point we have to say listen when
you go and go and go and go for years
and all of the facts are there and you
choose to ignore them or to claim that
they're wrong or whatever the case may
be at a certain point there are going to
be consequences for your actions and for
pillow it looks like it's racking up
about a 50 million dollar bill
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right there were three notable Trump
events over the weekend and I want to go
over them with you Joe Biden expected to
announce his re-election this week and
have an event of his own which we will
of course cover live and then have clips
for you when it happens let's start with
the first of three Trump events Trump
did What's called the nelk boys
interview people leave me voicemails and
they think it's the milk boys it's the
nelk boys okay very important to
understand completely deranged and
hilarious this was Trump I guess trying
to be
kind of like an everyday guy of sorts or
something like that but one of the
really interesting things is that Trump
for all of his praise of Florida and
DeSantis during the pandemic
he's now retroactively talking about how
terribly things went in Florida during
the pandemic now as is often the case
Florida is the epitome of mediocrity
Florida wasn't disastrously bad during
the pandemic and it certainly wasn't
very good they had a pretty high death
rate but certainly not the highest death
rate so anyway Trump now is doing this
whole thing where DeSantis proves that
he's bad because Florida was bad during
the pandemic why do you think he's well
like besides that because he's done a
pretty good job with Florida you agree
why do you think you're a better choice
than DeSantis well actually if you look
at the numbers he didn't do a great job
if you take a look at the numbers he's
very high on crime very high right he's
high on crime he's smoking it daily the
top uh almost at the top uh he I think
he gets good publicity although now
people are starting because I'm putting
out the covet numbers he didn't do well
on covet he had more deaths and almost
every country in Florida I hate to say
it because Florida's my state but he had
he did not have he did not do well it's
it's really it's very interesting I
don't want to knock anybody but to think
he did well on his public relations
because uh the numbers weren't what uh
they pretended to be with all of that
being said when you help somebody
I believe in loyalty you just don't do
what he did now he's out campaigning I
assume he's going to run but I think the
numbers are so bad now that a lot of
people are assuming that he won't run
and uh would you consider him like to be
your running mate I don't I I don't see
it I mean I don't see it we have a lot
of great people in the Republican party
yeah increasingly it is being suggested
that Trump is going to pick a completely
insane woman rather than a completely
insane man to run with him and Ron
DeSantis is
um so listen the the truth about Florida
and covid as with most of these things
that for a while they'll praise someone
and then they'll attack someone for the
exact same thing the truth about covet
is like Florida wasn't great and Ron
DeSantis made some pretty bone-headed
moves when it came to covet and Florida
and Florida uh in part thanks to being a
warmer state where people spend a lot
more times outside it probably mitigated
some of the disastrous effect of the
DeSantis coveted policy but Florida was
nothing to write home about it's not an
outlier when it comes to covid one way
or the other but Trump is making a big
deal out of it now the topic of
dictators came up during the interview
with the nelk boys and Trump of course
praised dictator Kim Jong-un and just
generally seems really impressed with
dictators this will come up later in our
segment on the show about Trump's
interview last night with Fox news's
Mark Levin about Trump's infatuation
with uh dictators but here's just a
little preview Trump talking about Kim
Jong-un another thing I want to ask too
something historic that I'm always
amazed by what you did is how you got
along so well with all these world
leaders especially Kim Jong-un now let
me I have to pause it right there and
I'm not going to pause it again during
this segment this Quest this shows how
the nelk boys don't know anything if you
know anything about the history of
American presidential relationships with
North Korean leaders it's not a surprise
that once an American president agrees
to meet with a North Korean leader
if he is impressed by the apparent
Charisma of that North Korean leader
they're going to say hey I did something
great it's amazing that I've been able
to maintain this good relation now in
person with this leader North Korean
leaders going back to Kim il's Son have
been interested in and wanted to meet
with American presidents and get the
exact sorts of photo ops that they got
from Trump because it's good for them
it's good for propaganda value it's good
for showing look we're we're respected
the way American presidents are and the
reason that these meetings haven't taken
place the way Trump did his with Kim
Jong-un in the past is that American
Presidents saw the propaganda value to
the North Korean leadership of such a
meeting and so they didn't want to do
those meetings without preconditions
pre-negotiations that the North Korean
leaders never agreed to Trump and and
these milk boys being impressed with the
way they were able to cordially meet
with Kim Jong-un it goes to their
naivete about how North Korea works all
right let's listen to the rest of this
what I did what was he like as like a
person because he's like such a
mysterious and kind of like figure no
one knows what he's like what is Kim
Jong well first of all he's very smart
and he's very cunning and he's very
ruthless how so like how what makes him
so smart well I guess genetically he was
born pretty smart he just it was bred
into him they bred in the intelligence
the way we want to breed math skills uh
who was it Candace Owens who said we
need to breed math skills into our kids
in order to be better than the South
Koreans I guess I don't forget he took
over a country of 23 and even though he
was sort of like it was like an
inheritance this is a country with smart
energetic people he from a very early
start
got it he took it over from his father
but very young and you had generals and
you had all of these people and armies
and you know every and he gained control
and let me tell you he is the boss of
that country but I got to know him very
well yeah might be interesting to lead
with an absolutely brutal dictator
oppressing in a completely uh almost
beyond words way about 25 of the North
Korean population
oppressing more softly another 50
percent of the population and creating
this kind of overclass of his sycophants
uh and suck-ups with another 20 you know
like that's where I would start rather
than cunning and amazing and incredible
what he was able to do okay only someone
who understands no history could uh ask
that question or answer it in that way
Trump at another point when talking
about this j6 song says he didn't even
know what billboard was or what iTunes
is until I guess a few weeks ago and it
was done by the j6 prisoners who have
been treated horribly when you see the
way antifa got treated did such
destruction and caused death
and these people were treated horribly
and they asked would I do a voice over I
did basically a voiceover of the song
and it went to number one
on Billboard on iTunes
these are names I never even heard of
three weeks ago but iTunes number one
billboard number one Billboard's like a
big deal because that's sort of like oh
yeah you would tell me but as you know
it wants to know it's Donald J Trump and
the j6 yeah interestingly iTunes has
actually been shut down years ago it's
now Apple music and then Apple podcasts
and Apple TV so one of the funniest
things is Trump says he didn't learn
about iTunes until a few weeks ago
it actually was shut down years ago it
it's all just a mess and this then
lastly during this interview with the
nelk boys Trump says if he was leading a
South American country he would just
dump the prison population and the quote
mental institution population
right into the United States which he
claims they are doing which they are not
who wants an open border where people
from mental institutions are being
dumped into the U.S where people from
prisons where entire prison populations
of countries are being and I do the same
thing if I was the president of a South
American orc not only South American
they're coming from all over the world
he may not know the names of any South
American countries which is why he
paused like that they're dumping their
prison population into the United States
of America they're dumping their people
from mental institutions and words that
aren't used anymore insane asylum did
you ever hear you're too young that's
where Silence of the Lamb of course
that's the lamb you know it's it's
Silence of the Lambs right where Silence
of the Lamb happens to be uh you know
what's it represented but insane asylums
these These are seriously sick they are
being dumped into the United States of
America yeah huge massive dumps they're
not happening though that's that's
untrue it isn't happening the most
depressing thing about the nelk boys
interview to me is that These Guys these
milk boys basically seem like suck-ups
to Trump they don't know anything about
history their questions they can't even
form an actual critical question because
they lack such knowledge and that's why
Trump is so impressed with them Trump
walks in and everybody's throwing
bouquets at each other and they got
Trump a gift whereas if Trump appeared
on a single podcast that could actually
assemble a logical interview uh you
would have a very different outcome that
I can assure you all right let's now
move to Trump's next weekend appearance
he appeared last night on The Mark Levin
program on Fox News this you have to see
the topic of Richard Nixon came up
um the disgraced former American
president and Trump delivered a
two-minute word salad that is almost
Beyond linguistic comprehension this may
be Trump's worst interview of the year
it's only April but folks that it'll get
worse but this may be Trump's worst
interview of the year so far let's
listen to Trump's completely confused
word salad when the topic of Richard
Nixon came up uh he was a very tough guy
he was I guess some people would say
this about me too he was his Own Worst
Enemy I mean I could say that a little
bit about myself much less so than
people think I will say but
um he was um
sort of a paranoid guy and that's okay
you know you keep your guard up that I
don't say that badly this is just an
electric amount of energy from Trump as
you can see you can also tell Trump's a
real history buff
his views on Henry Kissinger were very
interesting I won't tell you exactly I
get along pretty well with Kissinger but
I tell you his views on Henry Kissinger
we're not so hot and uh
he was a tough guy and he he they went
over to tell him that you have to get
out his biggest regret according to his
daughters and I think according to him
pretty much was that he didn't fight
they went over there one evening Barry
Goldwater headed up the delegation and
they had some senators and some
congressmen and they went over to tell
him he's got to get out
and he left the following day or the
following morning
and his biggest regret was that he
didn't fight
because it wasn't really like him
and I find that very interesting
and his daughter when I got impeached
twice by by the way it's not that Nixon
didn't fight yeah Trump the history buff
Nixon fought and fought and fought until
courts made him turn over the tapes that
shody was complicit complicit in the
Scandal and leaders of his own party
approached him and said we will impeach
you if you don't resign Nixon did fight
but the Republican Party had the
strength of will or the
moral Clarity I mean I don't want to
overstate it to say hey you you got to
go it wasn't made up of lunatics like
Jim Jordan and Marjorie Taylor green at
the time but Nixon did fight yeah really
crooked disgusting politicians you know
they just happened to have a majority
and they the Democrats do stick together
and they on a perfect phone call think
of it on a perfect phone call this was a
call that I remember Tim Scott the
senator from South Carolina read this he
was the first one to say he read the
call because I had it it was taped the
quote was taped he said he didn't say
anything wrong he was saying like what
did he do I was a perfect I was a
congratulatory call but I'll never
forget uh
when that happened we had such great
support Nixon had no support you know he
just didn't have support he was very
very tough with people just an endless
circular word salad uh I get along with
people I mean I I have great Jim Jordan
and all these congressmen are great that
they're really incredible people they're
fighting so Trump there's more but we'll
stop it there just electric energy from
Trump as you can tell then as I told you
earlier the topic of dictators came up
and I kind of like this question from
Mark Levin to a degree where he points
out you seem to really get along well
with genocidal Maniacs what's up with
that and I know Levin's not even really
trying to be tough but it is a funny
moment take a look at this and look keep
an eye on Trump's reaction let me ask
you a question about that you have
really fascinating letters in here from
Putin
from G
from UN in North Korea and I can go on
and when I notice there's a Common
Thread
you had a personal relationship with
every one of these leaders whether
they're genocidal Maniacs whether
they're elected like Abe of Japan who
was a close friend of yours and was
assassinated I want to get into some of
this
why would you say your foreign policy is
because I think people keep projecting
onto your farm power well Trump has no
idea what his foreign policy is
basically he just lusts for
authoritarian power and that's why he
admires these tyrants I'll see what it
is that they think they want people to
think your foreign policy is
what would you say it is so I think more
than anything else and it was a very
personal relationship and you know it
was sort of a weird situation the
tougher they were the better I got along
with them and that's probably a good
thing because it was a tough one had the
big powerful countries the ones that can
do destruction yeah this is so much
simpler this is so much simpler for
whatever reason you want to say it is
and you could say it's because of
Trump's relationship with his father you
could psychoanalyze you could you could
come up with 20 different reasons as to
why
Trump is enamored with these
authoritarian strongmen and sometimes
they are genocidal dictators he's
enamored with them Trump's not impressed
with diplomats like Angela Merkel or
Justin Trudeau Emmanuel macron he's he's
not it's not impressive and in fact
Trump's relationships with our
historical Western allies were
significantly uh damaged while he was
president and the U.S was increasingly
not even a part of many important
discussions with our historical allies
while Trump was President Trump was
enamored with the dictators and the
authoritarians and that's fundamentally
what it is and we could psychoanalyze
bag you know until the as long as the
day is we could sack we could uh
speculate about that
but that's the reality one more weird
moment from this interview with Mark
Levin on Fox News Trump says that China
raped America and I got it back in the
form of taxes tariffs and other things
and with hundreds of billions left over
and no other president got 10 cents and
yet I got along with President XI
incredibly well but I was stopping the
Rampage it was the rape of America
that's what it was it was the yeah the
rape China raped America is Trump's
latest thing these interviews mark my
words are going to get more and more
insane as Trump's legal troubles worsen
potentially with more arrests and
indictments and if Ron DeSantis does get
in the race which I don't know that he's
going to we'll talk about it if if
DeSantis does get in the race it will
also be hugely triggering to Trump all
right final Trump event from the weekend
that I want to go over Donald Trump gave
a statement of some kind the lighting
use for a while now the lighting has
been terrible on these Trump videos the
new thing now is that the camera is out
of focus
and also
um the audio is out of sync with the
video so what you hear doesn't seem to
line up with Trump's mouth very strange
speech but sadly one of Trump's main big
priorities if he were to become your
president again
is that he will put God back in schools
which is a really horrible thing to hear
so to traditional religious teachings
under my leadership we will bring back
God to our schools and our public
squares and that will happen very
quickly on day one we will begin to find
the radical zealots and marxists who
have infiltrated the Federal Department
of Education and we will have them
escorted from the building right so day
one they will find marxists of whom
there are essentially none in positions
of power anywhere
um and they will fire them I guess and
escort them out pandering to the
so-called evangelicals pandering to the
so-called Moral Majority and all of this
is It's really unclear that this is a
good idea this next clip I'm going to
play for you is Trump going hard
anti-abortion and again when you look at
public opinion it is not obvious that
the anti-abortion direction is the right
way to go we'll stand proudly in defense
of innocent life just as I did for four
very powerful strong years because every
child born and unborn is a sacred gift
from God so standard Hardline
anti-abortion language except the
country keeps moving left on that issue
and the anti-abortion push in the wake
of Roe v Wade's repeal was not a good
thing for Republicans last clip here
this one seems to be in sync which is
good better better quality at this point
in time but again Trump's spreading
anti-abortion lies I I will continue to
stand strong against the extreme
late-term abortionists in the Democrat
Party who believe in abortion on demand
in the ninth month of pregnancy and even
executing babies after birth they
actually talk Beyond birth after birth
executing the baby untrue of course this
has been widely debunked there's simply
no evidence of it part of this was
claimed to be out of New York couldn't
find any evidence of it part of it was I
believe Virginia they repeat it and
repeat it if you want to understand how
that claim enters the flex the standard
lexicon of abortion check out my clip
from Thursday the anatomy of right wing
propaganda and it'll tell you how rumor
becomes stated as if it were fact at the
very top of the Republican Party insane
weekend for Trump it's going to be a
crazy week for Joe Biden as well
expected to announce his re-election we
will have it all after this break we
will check in on uh where is Ron
DeSantis turns out he's not in Florida
again and much more stay with us
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show we haven't
heard from or talked about failed
Arizona Republican gubernatorial
candidate Carrie Lake for a little while
that's a good thing we should all be
glad about that she has not gone away
and now as she is considering running
for Senate in Arizona she spoke to the
San Diego California County Republican
party group and she suggested that I'm a
new villain has entered she suggested
that run back elect action services
illegally sabotaged or even sabotaged
her election and one of the things that
I want to explain here is
there are sometimes reports about this
type of thing that I don't think do a
good job journalistically so let me
first play for you what she said and
then I'll tell you more about it
election day happened and they were in a
panic and they said how do we stop this
middle-aged woman who's hell-bent to
shut down that border how do we stop her
and they said we're gonna have to
sabotage election day that's exactly
what they did starting at 6 a.m the
machines did not work on Election Day in
Arizona
the machines in 60 percent of our our
voting locations didn't work
there were lines four to six hours and
it was primarily in the Republican areas
it was so bad but what happened was they
intentionally printed the wrong image on
the ballot
run back somebody said it you're
following aren't you everyone knows this
they intentionally printed the wrong
image on the ballot it jammed the
machines 60 everybody knows it guys for
some of the polling places all of them
mainly in the Republican areas didn't
work this was a disenfranchisement of
the voter that I've never seen this big
in my life so she's mixing multiple
different conspiracy theories and also
pretending as though this run back thing
hasn't already been debunked and that's
how a lot of these people operate
there's a really irresponsible thing
that sometimes will happen when Kerry
lake or others put out a conspiracy
theory that is new to some people media
will sometimes reprint it without
including the fact that it's already
been investigated it's already been
debunked in this particular case an
expert witness hired by Carrie Lakes
lawyers did at one point testify that
ballots were found printed with the
wrong size image by Run election systems
but it's been investigated already
assistant Maricopa County attorney Tom
Liddy looked into it and said even if
the ballots were printed in the wrong
size as the witness claims it wouldn't
matter
he said the votes would have eventually
been counted anyway it wasn't an issue
in addition that would be partisan in
its effect in other words if there were
ballots printed on the wrong size paper
or whatever the claim is they would
equally affect Democratic and Republican
voters and all of these other things she
pulls into it there were 10 hour lines
or five hours there were lines at some
polling places for part of the day sixty
percent of the machines didn't work now
a few tabulators briefly didn't work the
Republican Party initially filed suit
and then said oh it's been fixed to our
satisfaction they pulled the suit all of
these things have been debunked but it's
targeted like a weapon at people who
don't know any better also targeted like
a weapon at people who don't know any
better continued claims from Kerry Lake
that God wants her to keep fighting for
this election she lost
we have to do it
if we just keep walking away
when they steal our vote
we're not going to have a country
believe me let me tell you there's about
a couple days I wanted to lay in the
fetal position in bed I'm not gonna lie
I'm a strong woman but there's been a
couple days where I just said I don't
want to do this
and God just kicked my butt out of bed
and said get back out there I put you in
this for a reason I didn't put a weak
person in this fight now of course it
seems it would have been easier for God
to prevent all of this if he wanted
Kerry Lake to be the governor and just
have her win the damn election but God
works works in mysterious ways and we
don't know who prayed in in contrast and
Counterpoint and the prayer might have
canceled out who the hell knows it is
not stopping and she wants to
potentially continue this into 2024 with
a senate run that's very scary stuff
I've got whacked out video of Ron
DeSantis in Japan
shaking and smiling I don't know if
someone told him you've gotta look
cheerful and this is how he did it but
the guy's personality really leaves a
little something to be desired Ron
DeSantis was asked upon I guess Landing
in Japan
um what's the deal with like you're
losing every poll to Trump which is true
and DeSantis is visibly shaking
and it's very strange I don't believe
this is a medical event but people are
studying this like the Zapruder film
suggesting it's a deep fake but it is
all too real look at this
I'm not I'm not a candidate so we'll see
if if and when that changes yeah really
weird stuff I'm going to play it for you
once more and
it it is strange strange stuff find that
a trumpet
I'm not I'm not a candidate so we'll see
if if and when that changes okay no by
the way there's no belief that this is a
medical event it the Ron DeSantis
doesn't have tardive dyskinesia or any
of these things we're not making fun of
medical conditions it seems as though
this is how he's been coached to be
upbeat to shake and smile like a um
horror clown like from a scary movie uh
I don't think this guy has what it takes
the latest polling continues to show
weak numbers for Des Sanctus a little
bit of a pop-up but basically still
between 23 and 24. uh the green line at
the bottom of your screen is DeSantis
the purple line at the top
is uh Trump still between 52 and 53
DeSantis or Des Sanctus or de
sanctimonious between 23 and 24 and the
this 50 number is a very important thing
if you're Ron DeSantis and you're
thinking about do I run do I not run
if Trump already has 53 percent
you could get all of the non-trump vote
over to yourself and you still wouldn't
have enough right you could pick up
Pence's four and Haley's four and Tim
Scott's 1.6 and Rama Swami's 1.4 you
could get all of that and you'd still
only have 47. so you know there's a
period of six weeks ago I would have
said DeSantis isn't going to be able to
get away from running he's going to run
I'm not so sure now I'm not so sure it
may actually not make sense for him to
get involved in this and if that's the
case Trump runs away with this thing the
argument for DeSantis to get involved
would be even if Trump already has 50
percent
you need to be there visible and holding
25 percent
in case Trump gets arrested again in
case Trump gets indicted again in case
it becomes clear Trump can't possibly
run a campaign amidst the chaos of one
two or three different indictments you
need to be there with 25 percent to then
pick up some of Trump's support if and
when it becomes clear Trump simply can't
do this that's the best argument for
DeSantis because the numbers right now
show a DeSantis that can't possibly win
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a very good
question about what happens if Trump is
the nominee and loses in 24. take a
listen to this it's something I've been
thinking about for sure
hey David
should we be worried about
what
what I'm gonna do if Trump loses in 2024
I believe we should be worried the
question really that's being asked
is
will Maga Riot again
if Trump loses in 2024. I hope the
answer is no
I pray the answer is no I don't even
pray but this I might pray for I I
really hope that they are not going to
Riot if he loses
um I do think it makes sense for law
enforcement to be more prepared Maybe
but uh honestly everything surrounding
Trump lately has been so low energy I
mean bear you know with the arrest that
we're going to be big protests there was
a protest with like 40 people and a
couple hundred members of the media and
police not a big showing let's hope that
Maga remains as deflated as they've been
and that no matter what outcome there is
there's no violence we're thinking very
far ahead and we're going to wait and
see on the bonus show today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money yeah
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves as bad number one we'll be
making money on the bonus show number
two the Supreme Court is preserving
access to the abortion pill for now and
for now is a big thing uh we will talk
about the continued expansion of AI
including songs written and performed by
AI are you an AI NPC listening to AI
music and you don't even know it what
would that do to you okay we'll talk
about that and we will also talk about
new polling this this is kind of just
depressing
majorities don't want Biden nor Trump to
run in 2024 based on new polling what
does it mean all of those stories and
more on the bonus show which you can
sign up for at joinpakman.com I'll see
everybody then or right back here
tomorrow
thank you